welcome to your mom's house
have you seen this yet I loved the show
my strange addiction we are in the bird
my name is Karl
I love Dayton grandmas I met this lady
online named Karen I saw our pictures I
thought I was absolutely right sir I'm
so looking forward to meet her tonight
did he say pictures I saw our pleasures
pictures it's like photography yeah
photography and I love looking at
pictures a lot of the pleasures of old
ladies what's a picture what do you
think his deal is what's the deal with
old Nana's he's Nana puss his fucking
grandma jerked him off and he was a
little baby and he's trying to get back
in there I think you're right you know
something weird happened with of course
gross I've got butterflies in my tummy
looks like you got butterflies in your
tummy and you've got rodents in your
mouth who talks like that and then she
shouldn't see could I have the same
thing this is fake this one's fake you
got to match them you can't just do one
front tooth here it's real brown hey and
that son can fix you know right you just
bond much like this this is tough to fix
this is what I'm gonna look like with
those eye bags yeah well we're gonna
fucking how do you fix that can you get
dry bags removed for sure of course I'm
gonna do that later yeah okay I tell you
what she doesn't look that bad if she
figured I don't think she looks bad at
all but I think her mouth is her Rena
Rendon what did it smell like it sounds
like fucking farts man it smells
terrible
I've got better flight why not
sighs in my country right now in my
diaper hasn't happened in so long she
looks sexy yourself the long platinum
hair wow it's so great to finally meet
you your pictures looking at all your
pictures and they're real pretty
everything aside she's crazier than cat
shit we can tell already yeah
this chicks in our fucking gear is too
crazy super wack it really does that's
so sweet of you just say that I look at
like all these celebrity women that are
going out with younger men and I thought
well you know maybe I should try it you
seem to be internment although I'm not
gonna say that I necessarily decided to
come out with you because of your mind
to be able to feel like this again you
know just think you know next but it
will be brand new what's gonna happen
next is your aural decay is gonna lead
to heart issues ever it is so you've
done a lot of traveling where did this
fool taker where like mozzarella sticks
are on the mini earth at Denny's I don't
know it's disgusting good somewhere nice
dude Olive Garden take a nap I'm so
tired
babe can I can I be good for her that
she's she's pulling some young tail yeah
I hate on that yeah it's just it's it's
crazy she looks crazy and we are more
conditioned to seeing old fucking piece
of shit
thank you yes wretched ugly dad Mouse
with hot young things hounds basset
hounds they look so horrendous yes
beautiful young women and you're like
yeah because you know of course but
she's in it she's getting you just
because his dick is hard with them yes
there's someone for everyone that's the
lesson to this story he kind of has
weird teeth too his lips are a little
red for my liking on the man yeah would
you go
like someone like me because I'm old
enough to be your mother definitely you
gotta make that ah
Langton is helpful and yet you gotta you
gotta start up fucking GoFundMe the
black decay isn't that cool
and that's neh that's not just fun
acceptable yeah fix your damn teeth you
don't you skip clothes you see yeah you
skip meals and you skip paying your
bills and you just get your teeth
fucking fixed yes that's what you do
when your shit looks like that yes god
damn it it is so upsetting
it's horrendous especially because okay
she doesn't need to get those big white
she doesn't need to get the Steve
Harvey's just needs to fix the decay on
that tooth and I'd say whiten just white
no look at what she or - yeah yeah I can
someone just do this work for her for
freaks like Beetlejuice like Michael
Keaton yeah totally yeah hello everybody
yeah cool really give me a little kiss
Oh Beetlejuice mouth totally oh she's
not totally I went yeah it's food
distance she goes get on all fours I'm
gonna have a little dessert from the
backside how do you think I got this
tooth all brown brown - wanna dance
cute the day with Karen was incredible
she was 100% my type yeah
oh god I'm gonna throw up oh that's it
had a wonderful time with pile and I've
had such an amazing time I just don't
want it to end
teto gonna throw up
that penis is pointing inward right now
so upsetting it really it's only the
tooth I don't care about the other stuff
no it's like dude just fucking get your
life get jar cuz man I'm telling you I
had to replace my two front teeth every
ten years and we were broke as a joke
but we put money yeah get mama teeth you
know we got we had debt from it you know
yeah yeah cuz it's that important that
is how important it is yeah I would say
there's a lot of things where it's not
worth the debt people want to do things
yeah things but things on your face your
face brown face is worth debt your face
go into debt for your mouth yeah your
mouth yeah yeah your mouth it's so
important it's so important how did she
smile you know when I got my veneers
done this time around the guy who did
them is this amazing craftsman yeah and
he said that people people don't smile
for years when they have jacked up tea
course and could you imagine not smiling
because you're ashamed of your teeth
clearly she's not got other people you
know I'm your muscles and your lips and
everything change over time yeah he said
that it takes a while to get used to
smiling when you get new teeth that make
sense it made me almost cry hearing that
like yeah that people don't smile
because they're to you yeah no I agree
it's it sucks it sucks